okay let me start to help you out I'm
going to use the same tools that we use
the call I'm going to think about this
function over here this is different it
doesn't have two asymptotes like we had
before how we asymptote is this has my
count 3 watch firstly the thing about
this limit theme is horizontal
asymptotes okay what happens so this
this whole thing when X gets really
really large you're going to get 1
divided by some ridiculously in others
not remember how we said this is going
to infinity or now this is going towards
infinity times infinity right this
sounds a bit like you know when you're
trying to argue with a friend with you
and like stickies on you're like well I
like it with inclusion plus one visit to
the power of infinity that's not
happening here this thing is growing and
throwing even bosses that we looked at
before okay what's one over this really
enormous of zero you can double check
this did you like and you'll notice
exactly the same thing happens when you
put in negative y equals zero y
presumably that's going to be my
horizontal asymptote
I am suggesting there are two more
asymptotes one RA is going to be one at
x equals negative one could look that's
what I want to talk you to zero and it's
going to be what he had x equals trips
to go ahead for the money
okay we've got asymptotes what would the
other important piece of information
that we need
yeah I'm looking for intercepts now
right so I'm going to let our X equal
zero when I let X equal zero
I get 1 over negative 2 so negative 1/2
okay then
one second why is it so I just said what
is it x-intercept
how about my x-intercept again I know y
equals zero and then you realize you
sort of got a problem what's the problem
do you remember we said before when
you're trying to solve something like
this you don't care at the denominator
anymore right because no matter what the
denominator is smaller the numerator is
zero
you're still zero right except if the
denominator doesn't matter right then
all you've got left is the one weight
back the earth
what berries of X would make that zero
yeah there are no values that make that
numerator 0 right he's one he doesn't
care what if this is equal to
independent vectors where we're saying
okay so what this needs is our sorry
guys you never actually collide with the
x intercept there are no zeros for this
function so now this is all I've got
left
except for this information overseer you
know that the buttons change sign around
the durations is continue and you know
that the year is indeed coyly is happen
because of the fact is right but you
have the same factors here and all the
other ones right so have a look at your
parabola on the left of negative 1 will
you above the axis or below the answers
you're about right you were up in this
area
is limited set by the state okay when
you look at your parabola in between
negative 1 & 2
where's your primal is important you
wanna give native down here and then of
course it's sort of travels up here it
does the same thing okay now read all
the information I need
I'm going to be up here and I've got the
two asymptotes to approach the only
thing I can physically do is this degree
like we've got to stay out there and you
sort of fit the advisee attitudes you're
an approaching one other shape you're
going to draw right you can't go away
you can't collide three because you
already decided there are no rectum
event that's all you can do okay what
about on the other side over here send
you all right you got to stay up there
you've got the adam2 expensing you in so
therefore this is the shape that you get
and then lastly you have to do weird guy
in here what do I draw in here
yeah similar to a parabola I want to
point out to let me draw him this is not
a problem and you can compare this shape
with the shape that you've got for Part
A can you tell me what makes this not a
parabola despite how parabola if it
looks x-intercepts you don't have to
have a crowd would have known parameters
there again travelers have no manners
right because what's this domain what
domain of a parabola you'll just go no
just water right through done yeah I can
take whatever okay
however we graph this we told me okay
when you there is from here you're going
to get those glasses so you can't cross
this is a domain restriction so
therefore it looks like a lot but if I
come in okay there's the graph right and
this by the way we call this a rational
function because it's a ratio like this
divided by this
and it's function because for each
finding performance
you okay so so it doesn't have a vertex
because it's not a problem okay but
you're asking what's that point up there
we will let decide this point once we
know calculus okay I can find it for you
right now if you want got that
interesting I'll do it after I take you
guys working but we don't have the tools
why yes
you